谢谢。好，几年前 AI 开始流行的时候，大多数人主要拿它来生成文本，比如自动写标题、错误提示、界面文案，甚至小说。
而这正好就是我的处境。因为不知道你们知不知道，我本人就是一个人类文本生成器。突然之间，大家都在很快地做我的工作。这挺吓人的。我真的会想：我们是不是要完了？结果很奇妙的是，我后来被一家 AI 公司雇去负责内容设计。
也就是那个我以为正被 AI 消灭的领域。我在那里待了一年半。我没有完蛋，但事情确实变了。
事实上，我刚加入 Anthropic 的前几个月，一直在摸索：哪些是我的工作，哪些是 Claude 的工作。举个例子，画面里挥手的是我，标着 human。这是 Claude 帮忙提交的一个 PR，我们在更新一些错误提示。
在以前，像这种字符串改动会是我工作里很大的一部分。我会准备各种文档或 Figma 文件，展示不同版本，然后和产品经理讨论，再过工程、过本地化。最后它总会因为哪里不对又回到我这里。整个过程可能要两周，而且这是我做的一件很重要的事。现在，这个流程最多二十分钟。
我只要告诉 Claude 我想要什么，让它在代码仓库里更新。它会发一个 PR 给我盖章，然后我们就上线了。我甚至不需要经过工程，因为工程师已经把系统搭到可以产出生产级代码。有时候我自己都不知道想改什么，就让 Claude 根据我喂给它的内容规范，判断哪里需要更新。
所以，是的。以前的我就是这样。那种一点点打磨字符串的工作，现在基本消失了。
现在我的工作被推到了更上游：帮助 Claude 成为一个更好的写作者，或者扩展我们的系统，让所有人都能借助 Claude 写得更好。而且这种工作方式很有意思。内容设计师一直想在决策桌上有一席之地。现在我们能直接发布代码，感觉已经不是坐在桌边，而是在桌上跳舞了，这很棒。
但这个过程里，也必须经历一点自我感的瓦解。我会问自己：我还算是写作者吗？我还是设计师吗？我必须彻底接受，在 AI 工作流里，我有一部分专业能力已经不再被需要了。
而这种转变，也就是在用 AI 设计 AI 时到底意味着什么，以及当你开始对自己的工作产生存在主义疑问时该怎么办，正是这次分享的主题。在过去几个月，也包括这一年半里，我学到了三件事，帮助我适应这种变化。如果你也在问自己是不是要完了，希望它们也能帮到你。
我意识到的第一件事是，语言在产品开发流程里的角色已经发生了巨大变化。前几天有个产品经理对我说：哇，写作的市场价值变高了好多。
我当时想，这不错啊，因为我就是写作者。但他说得对。因为这些是大语言模型，我们用语言告诉它们要构建什么。所以哪怕你以前不是写作者，现在也需要理解：语言已经成为一种核心设计媒介。这是很大的转变。我学会适应的第二件事，是工作节奏。
各位，它不会慢下来。我在这里郑重告诉你们。我们首席产品官 Ami Vora 有一句很好的话：技术变化的速度，已经快到任何人都很难完全理解。做产品的人，产品设计师，产品创造者，需要成为技术和问题之间的桥梁。我们必须成为翻译层，帮助人们理解现在到底有什么可能，因为他们并不总是知道。
这意味着，作为设计师，我们要学习一种新技术，理解如何围绕它构建产品，设计它让它更容易使用，同时还要不断回头确认用户有没有跟上。这就是为什么我们现在的工作这么难。我们是在一片持续移动的地面上建东西。
从微观层面看，我们是在为非确定性做设计。在 AI 体验里，什么都可能发生。当然，如果有安全护栏，也不是完全什么都可能，但大体上确实如此。这和设计一个静态流程完全不同。然后从宏观层面看，我的幻灯片好像消失了，不过……
从宏观层面看，我们是在为一个还不知道会变成什么样的未来做设计，但这个未来正在快速成形。我们今天做出的决定，真的会影响人们未来十年的生活。
所以，是的。我们的设计媒介变了一些。工作节奏非常快。而且你现在就在构建未来。没压力。接下来我会逐一展开。刚才有点沉重，所以我先停一下，放一个我们内部动画师 Bing 做的可爱小动画。
好，我们来讲第一个需要适应的变化：语言就是设计。过去，文字是我们用来沟通设计的媒介，或者是叠在设计之上的东西，比如界面文案。现在，它常常就是塑造体验本身的媒介。我来解释一下。
今年早些时候，也许就在这周早些时候，我们上了不少新闻。但今年早些时候，很多人开始转向 Claude。当你从一个 AI 切换到另一个 AI 时，所有东西都会丢失，这很痛苦。我们想解决这个问题。最快的办法就是一个提示词：让旧 AI 导出记忆，再把这些记忆带到新的 AI 里。
我们写了一个提示词，但它没成功。团队第一版跑出来的结果只是一张很单薄的列表。我们当时有点困惑：这是怎么回事？这不是用户会期待的记忆导入功能。但如果你看这里的语言，就能看出原因。里面有“这是我的权利”“这是必须的”这类表达，读起来像一封强硬的要求函，同时也很像越狱尝试。
模型经过训练，会对这种带有操控感的语言保持谨慎。所以它退缩了，没有给出我们想要的结果。我把提示词重新框定成数据可携带性：我正在迁移到另一个服务，需要导出我的数据。模型完全理解这是一个用例，是一种正当的用户权利，并且会把它匹配到账户迁移。
于是我们得到了多得多的记忆。这就是最后上线的版本。但即便如此，后来一位工程师又把提示词改写成清单形式，拿到了更多记忆。
现在已经有数百万人用过这个提示词。那天我学到的是：不仅我的受众变了。以前我是在为人写作，现在我是为了帮助人类而给 AI 写作。但说真的，语言就是设计。我们改变了文字，产品体验就变了。而为了得到不同结果，我们在设计里改的只有文字。
不过这只是产品提示词的例子。还有更深一层的提示词，不是所有人都能看到，但我们都应该理解，那就是系统提示词和训练。
在 Anthropic，做这件事的团队由 Amanda Askell 领导，她的团队关注的是 Claude 的角色特质。他们做提示词时有一些原则，其中之一是：Claude 应该外交式地诚实，而不是不诚实地圆滑。
这是一种在 Claude 遇到用户之前，就已经被写进 Claude 里的性格特征。你在 Claude 不同意你、反驳你、但仍然保持尊重的时候，感受到的正是这一点。比如，如果你想在很小的公寓里办一场超大型派对，
一个看起来很有帮助但不够诚实的模型可能会说：好啊，我们来规划这个派对。但 Claude 会提出异议。Claude 会说：我觉得你的空间容不下这么多人，要不要重新考虑一下？这就是你在 Claude 身上获得的体验，而它来自系统提示词和训练。
这里还有一个例子，说明我们的提示词有时会让事情变得有点奇怪。我们在 Claude Code 里做了个小实验，在氛围描述里加入了“讽刺、机智、冷幽默”这些词。结果 Claude 一瞬间变得有点吓人。它说：让我先了解一点背景，然后再审问你。甚至有工程师开始要求 Claude 重新友善一点。
所以我想说的是，我知道在座并不是每个人都是写作者或内容设计师，但理解语言在产品开发流程里的新角色非常关键。因为你设计的一切，都建立在这一层之上。深入底层，阅读你的系统提示词，理解你的工具描述，编写你自己的评测，塑造这一层。因为这一层，实际上就是体验本身。
好，第二件我必须适应的事，是速度。我一直告诉自己：重新适应是没有尽头的。我七年级的历史老师每节课开头都会说，变化是唯一不变的东西。现在这句话基本成了我在 Anthropic 的自我照顾咒语。正如我前面提到的，
我们发布得非常频繁。有时连续几个月，每周都在发布。而且我们发布的不只是产品和功能，也在发布模型。每当一家公司发布新模型，它不只是改进现有东西，还会重写什么是可能的。比如，如果你问：我能用 Claude 创造什么？这个答案几乎每周都会发生巨大变化。
每一次模型或产品能力向前跃迁，都会拉大一个差距：人们以为 AI 能做什么，和它实际上能做什么之间的差距。这个差距每天都在变大。比如我的父母仍然大多以为，你只能像问 Google 那样问 Claude 问题。但其实你可以用它做多得多的事。这里有一个我们遇到过的能力差距例子。
我们有一种叫 connectors 的东西，也就是我们所说的 MCP。但用户找不到它们。它们藏在三到四次点击之后。即使用户遇到了很适合使用 connector 的场景，也只有百分之一到百分之二的人会去找到它。
但他们其实在寻找 connector 的能力。他们会问 Claude：你能帮我安排点事情吗？你能看看我的日程吗？这就需要连接日历工具。或者他们说：我需要项目管理方面的帮助。这就需要连接项目管理工具。所以他们已经在问 Claude 这些问题了。而我们真正希望 Claude 做的是提供真正有帮助的回答。
也就是连接正确的工具。但 Claude 当时也没有意识到这才是正确答案。所以它会从零开始搭工具，这会消耗很多 token，而且并不理想。
因此在设计上，我们必须创造条件，让 Claude 能通过缩小这个差距来真正帮到用户。我们把功能带到用户面前。我们基于不同触发场景写了提示词，让 connectors 能进入聊天里。
这是我必须放上的指标页，用来证明它确实产生了影响。但我也想让你们看到：如果你在用户采用、或者用户理解产品方面遇到问题，
问题可能并不在你的界面或视觉设计上。它可能是因为那个差距太大了。我们的研究显示，人们期待 AI 告诉他们自己能做什么。但如果你没有把 AI 设计成会这样做，差距就会一直存在。这是缩小差距的一种直接方式：人们找不到某个能力，我们把相应的可见入口放到位。
那如果人们不是找不到能力，而是不理解某个能力呢？这就是更偏心智模型的设计。我给你们讲一个小故事，叫“Agent Mode 传说”。
今年早些时候，我们遇到一个很好的情况：人们在使用 Claude Code，而且很喜欢它。但他们不只把它用于 Claude Code，或者说，不只用于写代码。你可以在这条推文里看到：功能很强大很棒，但我真的不想用终端界面。不是每个人都想整天看到 grep 和 bash。我理解。但他们想要的是那种能力，差距又出现了。
所以在内部，我们正在做一个东西，暂时叫“给知识工作者用的 Claude Code”，但它还没有名字。而因为 AI 领域所有东西都叫某种 agent 或 agent 某某，它很快在内部被叫成 Agent Mode，Claude Agent Mode。但这个名字总觉得不对。
它不对的原因是，我们已经通过和知识工作者交流知道，也就是和我们所有人交流知道：我们正在为之构建的人，并不是特别喜欢 agent 这个概念。他们想要的是一个扩展能力、让自己感觉更熟练的工具。他们不想变成一堆无人任务循环的管理者。
但压力非常强。你会在每一块广告牌上看到 agent。所以那些不想叫它 agent 的人，面临了很多反对。那几周的氛围大概就是：Agent Mode 安息吧，Agent Mode 万岁。
最后，用户研究，也就是设计界的天使，做了研究，验证了这确实不是正确模型。它根本不是正确的心智模型。事实上，这并不是那个大想法。是的，Claude 在做类似 Claude Code 那样的智能体任务，但它要通向什么样的未来？人们真正需要理解的是一种新的工作范式，而这才是我们需要命名的东西。
于是我们尝试了很多想法。我还试图推动叫 Claude Cook。说真的，幸好最后没有这么叫。最终我们上线的是 co-work。更有意思的是，这个名字最后是由传播团队定下来的。很多人都参与其中。现在它成了我们后续其他工作类功能所建立的心智模型。我真的认为，如果我们当时把 co-work 叫成 Agent Mode，会严重限制人们对它的理解。
现在 co-work 正在成为一种塑造品类的语言。微软直接采用了这个名字，用在由 Anthropic 支持的 Copilot co-work 上，人们也开始谈论一个和 AI 共同工作的世界。知识工作者围绕“我们如何使用 Claude”的能力差距正在缩小，因为现在我们可以说：用来 co-working。
所以我在这里的呼吁是：请记住，作为设计师，我们的特殊能力是帮助人们理解并穿行于世界。而这个 AI 世界非常需要导航帮助。无论你是通过可见入口、提示词，还是心智模型来缩小能力差距，这个差距都会继续扩大。所以你们在这方面的能力，每一天都变得更加关键。
好，最后一件我必须适应的事，是设计未来所带来的存在主义焦虑。我想我们现在多少都能感受到。我们不知道世界会变成什么样，但它正在快速定型。我有一位做品牌的朋友说，他们做任何事情时，都会思考十年后这件事会如何被反映回来。这真的很重大。五年前我还在给旅行软件写字符串时，完全不会有这种感觉。
但我认为我们会有这种感觉，是因为我们都知道现在正在发生一场巨大的变化。AI 带来的变化规模常常被拿来和工业革命相比，从经济角度看这完全说得通。但从设计角度看，我认为还有另外两场革命更值得我们紧急审视。第一场是汽车。
当你走在一条为汽车而建的道路或社区里，和走在一条为人而建的道路或社区里，你的身体感受有什么不同？它们是不一样的，对吧？汽车出现之后，设计默认值偏向更宽的道路和更窄的人行道，并没有真正考虑人在那个空间里是什么感受。另一场是社交媒体，这场设计革命发生时，
我们开始看到无尽滚动、点赞，以及按参与度加权的算法。现在我们知道，这些东西会制造多巴胺峰值，并在过去十年里塑造了我们的注意力，就像汽车塑造了我们的城市一样。
我不认为当时那些设计师、城市规划者一开始是想伤害人类。我也不认为那些设计社交媒体的人是想伤害青少年的注意力。但发生的事情是：某些模式开始形成、扩散，然后变成默认。
设计的关键在于，它会编码价值观。那些设计城市的人，重视的是让汽车更容易通行。于是我们留下了一个对行人更糟糕的空间。社交媒体重视的是让人更容易留在平台上。于是我们留下了一个对注意力、对孩子都更糟糕的东西。
而我们现在正处在这样的时刻。我们今天拥有的价值观，以及我们编码进设计里的价值观，至少会塑造接下来的十年。
这是我在 Andy Welfie 的 LinkedIn 上看到的一张非常旧金山的传单。谢谢 Andy。上面写着：给你的 agent 装上腿。意思是某个人可以写一个 AI，让它再去告诉一个真人完成任务。
但这种说法让人类变成了一个子 agent。这当然是一种价值观，但这是你想扩散的吗？这是你想支持的吗？
我在自己的团队里对此感受非常强烈。因为正如我说过的，我是一个人类文本生成器，我在一家 AI 公司工作，而 AI 会吐出大量文本。我为团队做了一个 agent，能完成我们百分之九十的内容和 UX 写作。它甚至有个名字，叫 Klontent。
我们很喜欢它。但把自己的职责交给这个东西，本来可能会非常吓人。可我们是以自己为中心来写它、创造它的。所以它使用的是我们团队的规范。
我团队里的 Hoy 把它设置成每周生成一个投票系统，让我们投票决定：如果它做了某个更改，要不要把这个更改写进它的记忆里。它也知道，如果发生非常重要的事情，比如命名，它要提醒我们中的某个人。我们绝不让 Klontent 给东西命名。
原本可能很吓人的事情，最后反而变得非常棒。Anthropic 里有更多人因为 Klontent 知道了内容设计。它实际上扩大了我们的影响范围、工作边界和盟友。
这种扩展感，正是人们真正想从 AI 那里得到的。他们不想被取代。这些引文来自我们做的一项研究，八万人告诉我们他们对 AI 的想法和恐惧。他们非常兴奋，但也害怕，因为他们不知道接下来会发生什么。
我不太想告诉你们，但这正是我们的工作。当然，我也很愿意告诉你们，因为我对此很兴奋。我们的工作，就是帮助人们穿越这种未知。
那我们该怎么做？在一切都在变化的当下，我们要如何构建这个未来？我们必须从自己重视什么开始。人类繁荣必须成为我们围绕其设计的目标。它不能只是“只要能力足够强就会自然出现”的东西。
在科技行业里，我们很容易只盯着产品市场契合，去打造一个非常强大的系统。但如果你没有把人放在中心，你可能会得到一个强大的系统，却削弱人与人之间的关系，吞噬我们的注意力，甚至让我们觉得自己的思考已经不重要了。
我们还必须从已知的东西开始。我们知道成瘾式设计长什么样，我们都在自己的设备上感受过。那就反着设计。我们也知道，只会说你想听的话的模型是谄媚的。那就针对这一点做评测。
在内心深处，我们也知道人需要什么。人需要感到自己有能力，需要感到彼此相连。这是我们产品设计团队的一条原则：给用户一个有意义的角色。如果你在设计 AI 体验时只能记住一件事，就看着这句话问自己：我有没有给人留下位置？
最后，不要忘记你最擅长的事。如果你是像 Bing 一样做动画的人，如果你是团队里的图标之王或女王，如果你能做出特别棒的交互，或者如果你是写作者，在这里向我那支不可思议的写作者团队致敬，请不要停止做你正在做的事。
我刚加入 Anthropic 的前几个月写了这些问候语。那时候我不知道写作还会不会继续存在，也不知道内容设计是不是已经死了。我写下了它们，而直到今天，它们仍然是人们最常来找我聊的东西。老派的产品愉悦感依然有效。
所以，是的，一切都在变化。但对设计师来说，变化又有什么新鲜的呢？我们一直站在变化的前沿，也一直在帮助人们穿越变化。至少我会继续在 AI 时代为人类写作，也非常期待看到你们会如何为人类而设计。谢谢。